l'histoire de ce petit village encerclé
par les romains nicolas cornu nombre
d'un côté les braves gaulois dans leur
village de l'autre les cruelles romain
plus nombreux mieux armé mais les
gaulois ont la potion magique et le duo
infernal astérix christian clavier
obélix gérard depardieu particulièrement
bagarreur il adore jouer avec les
romains quoi c'est pas la bagarre à l'ao
lydiane c'est vraiment une set c'est la
bagarre à la gauloise gauche où c'est un
peu le côté western quelque chose
l'américain adam sissoko toulouse aime
bien les france des franges de dany
veulent plus jouer avec tous les romains
les mairies mois jésus mini est un gros
l'arraché une raclée c'est vexant aulas
oui quel et qui tu parles d'un des tout
à fait naturel que je fasse obélix
puisque c'est pas tellement par
l'appétit mais c'est par l'énergie et
puis ce côté un peu naïf cas obélix non
pas bête un cessez-le-feu différentes à
peu naïf pichot de faire un obélix
amoureux
le feu amoureux qu'il fait un régime
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de manger trois
sangliers ne mange plus que deux c'est
assez joli
si de nombreux personnages existait dans
la bande dessinée certains ont été
inventés je me dis que je ne suis plus
maître de tous nos personnages
parce que quand on voit des comédiens
qui sont quand même les grosses
pointures jouer ce que ce que vous avez
créé il ya quelque chose il ya un fossé
qui sépare d'un seul coup on sent
toujours dans le coup bien sûr mais on
semble nettement qu'on ait pu mettre de
tous à 260 millions d'albums s'étaient
vendus dans le monde entier
ce cinéma populaire à grand spectacle
brillant distribution et abondance
d'effets spéciaux est une potion magique
qui devrait doper et faire exploser les
records du cinéma français